good morning believe nation today's
message is go hard over to you GE Z go
hard and then when you think you're
going hard go harder like that's really
is just hustle you know I mean is
there's nothing in life that you can't
you can't put enough work in every
single day and not get better at you
know what I mean like if you want to be
good at something you know I mean like
you can't just like not like do it every
day and not get better this is
essentially what musics the same she's
learning how to play an instrument so if
you spend your time practicing your
craft like you know that's really it's
just you know because nowadays like with
the internet everything is so accessible
and you know everybody in the world is a
rapper you know what I mean everybody's
putting music out so it's like how do
you stand out quality is always gonna
matter but also being different you
can't try to be different you know I
mean but you just gotta be yourself
every major breakthrough that you'll
have in your life will come from raising
your standards every major breakthrough
that you have in your life will come
from raising your standards you may tell
yourself that you're working hard you
may think that you're working hard right
now in your business may be for you
working hard means you know X number of
hours and in the past whenever you
worked less than that you felt like a
slacker but now you feel like you're
working hard
maybe compared to your friends and your
family or the people around you you're
working really hard maybe they tell you
you working really hard and so you feel
like you're working really hard but
you're not getting the results of you
are and maybe it's time that you need to
raise your standards a little bit I bet
if I came in if you said that you're
working hard and I came in and audited
your day there'd be a ton of wasted time
and I'm not just talking about now you
need to wake up an hour early or two
hours earlier and get more work done
sleep the same number of hours look in
the you know 16 17 hours that you are
awake there's a lot of wasted time in
there
whether it's checking your social-media
refreshing your email all the time
responding to a crisis that isn't really
a crisis not spending your time on the
valuable things that you need to do to
grow your business constantly being
interrupted and distracted and it's not
their fault to interrupting and
distracting you it's your fault for
allowing it to happen there's a ton of
waste of time in what you're doing every
single day and as long as you think that
you're working hard as long as you think
that you're doing your best then you're
never going to do better if you say this
is the best I can do you're never going
to do better and you're gonna be stuck
where you are now you're happy where you
are great but don't complain that you
want more don't complain that you want
more you're not willing to raise your
standards and put in the work and get
better to get there so I look at the
change in my schedule where now I'm
recording all my videos as a test all my
videos in one day once a month for the
entire channel making 70 videos in one
day and when we first came up with this
idea like I liked it I liked the push I
don't know if I can do it I don't know
if I'm gonna be able to sustain but I
want the challenge to test it and see
because I thought I was already doing a
lot because everybody around me would
say listen you're making three videos a
day that's crazy how do you make three
videos a day where most people working
hard is making even a video a day as we
consider working really hard we're doing
three a day and to record them all once
a month is nuts but I want the test I
want to see where my limits are if
you're never pushing for your limits and
you don't know what you can do if I said
the best I can do is once a week then
that's what I'm gonna stick to doing and
I'm gonna be wasting some time so I'm
gonna try this is our first test doing
once a month can we make it happen can i
still be good making 70 videos in a day
can my team handle the influx and get
everything ready do I lose momentum and
I'm okay with failing I'm okay with it
not working out but I'm not okay with
not knowing and so you want to be taking
on challenges to push yourself to
understand where your limits are and
work on busting through them
every major growth that you have in your
life every single major move forward
will become by adjusting your standards
when you demand more from yourself when
you start teaching people how to treat
you
that's when you're gonna get the next
major breakthrough in your life and in
your business so the question there
today is I'm curious what was the last
standard that you raised for yourself in
your life or in your business where you
said I'm no longer willing to tolerate
this anymore
my new standard is up here this is what
I want to accomplish what was that last
one for you leave in the comments and
we'll join in the discussion I also want
to give a quick shout out to Tom Kelton
Tom thank you so much you're picking up
a copy of my book here one word it
really really really really means a lot
to a man and I hope you're enjoying it
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso hey believe nation thank you so
much for watching if you want to learn
more about this subject get a little bit
deeper on it I'm gonna share some extra
bonus clips that I hope you'll enjoy
long before I got my record deal the
streets
with a little bit of keyboard okay with
glasses on like I was Stevie one you
know I think hustling you know put a big
chitling bucket I paid my rent and my
mom's rent offer street performing but I
only do it three days out of the week
just three days but I would because I
get I can't even talk because I was like
singing from mic for like eight hours
straight for people going to work and
coming from work
then I will hitchhike to LA but I lived
on the beach you know car or box and dig
these tiles I slept on the beach on the
beach every day
and then I wake back up when I wake up I
see again
[Music]
then I can't hitchhike back to Chicago
and then I got discovered but I did all
that for like six years street performer
well a lot of artists don't know that
they got to get on the goddamn Road and
tour you know so you gotta get the
people knowing about you man you know
not just your hot single man you got to
get out there in politic how do you
politic I'm torn man
you don't saying merchandise did you got
a shirt with your name on it you got a
hat with your name on it you know these
people are walking billboards you know
exactly you know you got it you got to
get out there and politic man and that's
how we did it man we just stayed on the
road it feels like seven people in the
audience when we went we didn't say okay
we ain't going back to San Diego because
the only seven people there or we ain't
going back to New York cause we only had
ten people there we kept coming back and
hammering on from hammering them over
the head and the seven turn to a hundred
one hundred turn the five hundred you
know stances selling out every time but
we got to change venues you don't say
you got to get out there and politic man
you got to get out there and tour you
got to get out there and sell your
merchandise man and and a lot of people
you know I think I'll tell you this but
it take a little money to start your own
label you feel me it take a little money
to start it you know I mean so are you
[ __ ] selling ice